[Música]
es la historia de empresas pocos comunes
anacrónicas a su época
marcas de excelencia en las que los
artesanos con dedos de oro perpetuan el
saber hacer de antaño para crear
maravillas actualmente
en tours se encuentra una de estas
empresas distintas a las otras detrás de
esta fachada de un patio se esconde un
mundo imaginario onírico y colorido
[Música]
en ese taller se crean papeles de
colgadura excepcionales y se recrean los
que han desaparecido
Este es un documento de 1780 más o menos
Entonces vamos a reconstruirlo
totalmente
françoiser fundó este taller hace 20
años sin saber nada sobre la tipografía
una apuesta para este joven hombre que
se sumergió en el estudio de las
técnicas del siglo XVIII aquí por
ejemplo no se usa tinta sino un material
muy especial para encontrar la esencia
de los colores de antaño la mayoría son
pigmentos provenientes de la oxidación
de metal y de minerales
entonces O crees tierras cosas así
luego el color es esparcido en el papel
con cepillos de seda conforme a las
técnicas ancestrales
es el fondo del papel de colgadura los
motivos son aplicados gracias a la
prensa un color a la vez
con mi plancha sobre el papel
presiono una vez
y listo vuelvo y lo hago 11 impresiones
diferentes son necesarias para este
papel de colgadura pedido por un museo
de Filadelfia cada realización es única
y está destinada a los lugares de
prestigio alrededor del mundo Esta es la
farmacia Santa María novela es uno de
nuestros consentidos Este era el hotel
jacobs en uno de los más antiguos
documentos de papeles de colgadura que
tengamos aquí
el éxito que recompensa un largo
recorrido de iniciación hasta dominar
este oficio de la artesanía de
excelencia
no se puede hacer más rápido que la
música y está el aprendizaje que se
logra mucho con la práctica No es
solamente teoría había que Mostrar lo
que se es capaz de hacer que se podía
pretender ser lo que se denomina un
artesano de arte en este taller de
turango se hace inmersión en un período
previo a la guerra época de
despreocupación y escapadas y durante
las cuales los vehículos aún eran
fabricados a mano y es exactamente lo
que se hace aquí Frank es el jefe del
taller y sin no sabía mucho de
automóviles
tengo una formación de carpintero
ebanista me enseñaron a dibujar
escaleras en espiral que tienen la misma
técnica que estos vehículos
y que cambie la carpintería por los
automóviles
de la estructura de madera a la
carrocería pasando por la mecánica donde
cada pieza es refabricada A mano el
taller se especializó en la restauración
y la reconstrucción de los vehículos más
prestigiosos de antes de la guerra
Bugatti lancia delash mitos el automóvil
que recobran vida gracias al trabajo de
estos artesanos
estos vehículos en la medida en que
había madera cuero había materias nobles
una una tenemos la sensación de poder
transmitirle una época a una generación
que llega a estos oficios sí
maximilium es el último empleado en
haber sido contratado en el taller Hay
que ser meticuloso
es de los oficios donde todo toma tiempo
hace un poco más de años que estoy aquí
y el lancia que vimos ahora acaba de
salir
fueron tres años de trabajo todo un
equipo trabaja en ello
yo tal vez pasé unas mil o Mil
quinientas horas en ello Entonces es
cierto que hay que amar lo que se hace
amar el trabajo para ir hasta el final y
no abandonar
una suave sonoridad que recompensa las
horas de trabajo y la paciencia es
también la búsqueda cotidiana de Oliver
hace 40 años que Olivia concibe y
bajones en el norte de euceteloj
instrumentos nuevos y otros
reconstituidos a partir de Originales
fabricados entre los siglos 15 y 17
Quise ver cómo eran fabricados los
instrumentos de la época como eran
y los vi
los medí los copié
y así empezó apoyándose en los dibujos
de la Edad Media o del renacimiento
Olivier resucitó decenas de instrumentos
largos años fueron necesarios para
encontrar Maderas duras algunas secaron
durante 15 años aquí hay varias Maderas
este es boje una bella sección de boge
para los ovoes barrocos en madera
clásica esto es Ébano para los ovoes
modernos
finalmente para los bajones Arce Estas
son las Maderas primero debe perforar la
madera esta etapa determina la acústica
del instrumento luego viene el torneado
y finalmente la instalación de las
claves de los bajones es la parte
metálica
hoy el dueño transmite su artesanía
nos inscribimos en una cultura en una
tradición de saber hacer
y gestos que hay que aprender y
practicar
hacer revivir la sonoridades de
instrumentos antiguos pero también
recordar las decoraciones murales de
antaño o los vehículos de antes de la
guerra
tanto saberes antiguos vigentes hoy en
día para que viva el patrimonio
artesanal
[Música]